i have a pair of scissors um because i
want to talk about a piece of mask
called the fold and cut theorem it's one
of those things in mata where they just
name it what it is this first came to my
attention when i was trying to cut a
square hole in a piece of paper so
like my first instinct as a person who
cuts holes in paper was to jab a hole
and then cut around the edge of the
square but i thought okay maybe there's
an easier way to do this and
kind of my mathematical brain kicked in
and i realized that if i fold this in
half like that
i can just cut along those three edges
okay i've
roughly approximated the hole i was
originally trying to draw there's a
square hole um and i guess
like the mathematician in me was like
can i do that more easily can i make
this more efficient so what i thought
then was if i fold this twice so i make
the first fold
the same
and then fold that
at 90 degrees to that
i now have this bit of line and i can
now cut two cuts like that
and
i'll end up with
my square hole
two cats it's yeah it's two cuts it's
less than three cuts it's more efficient
um but of course you want to optimize
this so you know your mathematically
efficient way of doing this for just a
square is to start off with
one fold in half
a second fold
like that
and then your third fold is a diagonal
fold through that corner so as long as
you get all of those kind of folds
exactly right and the lines that you're
cutting along are all lying on top of
each other you can now cut out the
entire square the whole shape with just
one straight cut
like that
and this is the moment of truth a bit
where you don't really believe what
you've done has worked
but it turns out square is pretty much
the easiest one to do it is efficient
and it's it's one straight cut
and this kind of idea like i went to the
pub uh as you do when you've discovered
a nice thing uh and i was like i wonder
if this is a thing you can do in general
i wonder what shapes you can cut out
with one cut
and a friend of mine who was in the pub
said isn't that a theorem
uh as as all mathematicians will tend to
do i went and looked up that it is a
theorem it's called the folding cut
theorem and it says that any shape whose
edges are all made up of straight lines
can be cut out with one cut if you're
prepared to fold the bit of paper which
is just insane and i love this it was
proved by a guy called eric domain and
the team of other researchers they've
proved that it is possible to cut out
any straight-line edge shape even if
it's got more than one bit to it even if
it's got a hole in the middle you can
make one cut and cut out the whole thing
there are various examples of this
throughout history so harry houdini the
magician
used to apparently do a star with one
cut as part of his magic show and it is
sufficiently impressive to go in a
houdini magic show it turns out so i've
looked that up and i've figured out how
to do that so it's in half first
it's
in half that way and in half
that way
to get a cross shape and then the fold
is
there
and in theory that should give you 108
degrees ish
you can then fold that one in half
fold that back and fold that and you can
tell you've done it right because that's
the same size as that
ish and there's actually a nice little
story behind this because apparently
when
uh america was founded in the 1770s
they needed a flag and they went to see
a seamstress called betsy ross i don't
know if it's a true story it could be
one of these made-up stories that george
washington walks into a fabric shop and
was like i'm gonna need a lot of stars
cutting out
and she had a piece of fabric and she
just grabbed it and folded it up like
this and she did the one cut
so it's from there
kind of up that way
and she unfolded this and showed george
washington that she'd cut out a perfect
five-pointed star
with just one cut
and this the story goes that uh he was
like oh well you can make all the flags
then and she then had like work for life
making all of the american flags and at
that stage there were only like a few
stars on the flag they kept updating it
and adding more stars so she had to
remake all the flags so it was quite a
decent amount of work uh just because
she happened to know this little trick
uh and i love that i love that the most
like the most impressive thing for me is
that not only have you got a star you've
also got a piece of paper with a
star-shaped hole in it that's that's a
five-pointed star
uh that's that's my favorite bit is that
you get the opposite thing as well
because it is just that line that's cut
it's nothing else the next thing in the
paper that they list in kind of things
that they've seen was that someone had
once seen an example of someone who
could cut out any letter of the alphabet
on demand
and i looked this looked this up and
tried to find it and i couldn't find
anyone who did this i was like right
well that's i'm going to do that i'm
going to figure out how to do every
letter of the alphabet and it turns out
it's not even just um a cool thing to be
able to do it's actually a really fun
thing to work out
so you start with these simple letters
like l
because they're quite easy that's just
one kind of diagonal fold and then you
need to make the ends
you can do things like oh as long as you
don't mind it being quite square
and then things gradually get more and
more difficult and the the easier ones
tend to be quite symmetrical so t is
quite easy
s is not easy
s is a bit of a nightmare but it is
possible so i've worked out a full
pattern for every letter of the alphabet
having done this i then got an email
from someone saying i've just found this
pdf with a fold pattern for every letter
of the alphabet i was like oh what
that already existed oh well never mind
but it you know the the system that i've
worked out i'm happy with uh is slightly
different in places uh but you know
there are these things out there but it
is more fun to work it out yourself well
we've got a b c d e f g h i j and k
and then l m n o p q r s t u v w x y and
z
that's an a
that is b
that's c
that is d
e
that one's f
g
that's the closest i can get to g
without any curves
little h as i
j
this of course is my initial okay
that is completely different from j
that's l
that one is m
that is there's no way i'll get this
right where is that the right way around
yeah and
oh
it's p it's good enough it's tiny it's
tiny but it's a q
that's r
nice bit of a nightmare that one
this worked
well
yep
certainly funky t
u
slightly 70s looking v
so that's w
x it's quite a fun one to
to work out
it's time
very happy that's a why
it's looking good it's looking good from
there isn't it
so that's
zed like working out how to fold that is
such a mathematical thing to do like
it's it's the the type the type of
thinking that mathematicians use can be
applied to so many situations and this
is exactly one of them uh but this is an
example of something which also
mathematicians have properly used you
know mathematical analysis on and
they've proved a thing about it which is
you know for me that's what maths is
about it's not about calculating things
it's about proving things and it's about
understanding how the universe works and
it turns out that in this universe one
cut
suffices we'd like to thank linda.com
for supporting this video now linda's
great they have a huge range of video
courses
i was actually going through the catalog
earlier and came across some great ones
about how to use typefaces and
topography this is something i find
really interesting this one here is
called the 33 laws of topography and
it's gone right to the top of my watch
list i'll be having a look at that one
soon i think but whatever it is you want
to learn whether it's something creative
techy maybe just getting better at
business linda will have something for
you
there's over 3 000 video courses and 100
000 tutorials in the vault you can sign
up now for a free 10-day trial that's
unlimited access to all those videos by
going to lynda.com
numberphile or clicking on the link in
the description
that's linda
l ynda.com
give it a try and our thanks to linda
for supporting number five
um i did a show at cheltenham a couple
years ago
and um
one of the the things that i did in it
was as the challenge like to pick a
person in the audience asked them what
their name was and then cut out that
word while explaining the math behind
this i it was brilliant i asked for a
four letter word
um as then it was like anyone got four
not call it a name and this guy shouted
his name and i can't remember it was
produced five letters
and everyone was like mate that's five
letters and it was it was just a gift it
was hilarious